so machine learning in the warehouse
with python and snowpark really excited
to give this talk
uh as mentioned
um I work for deep note we build this
amazing data science notebook platform
you'll get to see it in Action a little
bit later I actually am a Solutions
engineer as of recently so I get to use
all of my data science skills and uh I
get to work with our customers help them
Define solutions that work for their
workflows it's a very very exciting role
my background and my sort of First Love
is really in the field of Neuroscience
and statistical software development and
so I've been very interested in in
taking
statistics that might be sort of
intimidating for some folks and and sort
of bringing it in in communicating in a
way that the rest of us can actually
make use of so
um that's a bit about me I want to tell
you a little bit about uh deep note and
snow park and how they can work together
at snow park does a lot of different
things and so I will try to break those
things down for you and so you can see
how you might use it for your own
machine learning work data science work
I wanted to give you just a little bit
um
of a pathway of this sort of dag or the
sort of process that I'm going to be
describing in this notebook that I'll
show you a little bit later on
but if you look at this um this
schematic here
um this visualization I want to show you
how we can take data from this sort of
initial transformation or raw uh form
which of course is you know all data
starts in the sort of raw form and then
we take it through a series of
Transformations making it more and more
readable for humans as we move from the
left to the right eventually you get
into this stage where you're exploring
your data you're visualizing it you're
trying to figure it out and you're kind
of getting into it as a data scientist
and then
once you're sort of done with this Eda
or exploratory data analysis you start
prototyping your models you know you
start taking a small sample of data
seeing you know learning the
correlations in your data and
prototyping it and then eventually
um you want to train your model fully
and deploy it so you really start with
this raw data set and you move it
through a series of stages until it's
something that you can use for machine
learning so this is a very generalizable
workflow
so things that we're going to learn with
respect to snowpark and deep note to
some extent
we're gonna I'm gonna show you how we
can write SQL without actually writing
SQL this is going to be useful for
people who prefer python
we're going to learn how we can do Eda
otherwise known as exploratory data
analysis without actually writing a lot
of code
and um we're gonna we're gonna look how
how we can actually do machine learning
but minimize the amount of data that we
have to move back and forth from let's
say our client to our server or our
local laptop to some remote cluster or
something so we're going to see if we
can minimize some of those rough edges
uh without changing our without moving
our data around or changing our tools
and I'm going to actually give you a
demo of this as well so
um you can see it in action and I will
be providing all of the resources that I
show with you so you can play around
with it as well
so
on the way to the demo I wanted to just
give you
even right now just an overview of what
I mean by all of these these things that
I'm I'm sort of summarizing already
what do I mean by writing SQL without
writing SQL well for those of you who
are familiar with pi spark or
duckdb or pandas you know that working
with a data frame API or a data frame
abstraction in Python is quite useful
and you can do SQL like things with it
well with snowpark it's no different
with snowpark you can very easily do SQL
types of things but just using python
methods that on objects that snow park
makes available to you in this
particular example I'm I have two data
sets DF demo DF serve it's just a
demographics table and a Services table
from a telecommunications data set
and then I'm joining the two of those
together on customer ID that's the third
line and then I'm actually writing that
new joined table uh as a new table in my
warehouse so you can see this is a very
sql-like thing to do but it's quite nice
um working with this in Python
now snowpark as I mentioned does a lot
of things one of the things that it
allows you to do
of course is aggregate Aggregates group
buys Transformations all sort of being
controlled from let's say a python
interface like a notebook but it's
actually running in the warehouse and so
this is really helpful for fast Eda of
course and here you can see a really
simple example something that you might
be familiar with again if you're
familiar with pandas or Pi spark where
I'm grouping by two dimensions in my
data and I'm doing some aggregation and
some sorting and so without really
having to do much I can already start to
make sense of my data
now again snow park does a lot of things
not only does it do all of this sort of
transformation with this data frame
abstraction
but it also it can also help you to
train and deploy your machine learning
models actually in the warehouse and
this this is quite interesting because
it's often a problem when you you're in
a notebook you have the limitations of
your laptop you want to train a model
and then eventually you want people to
be able to interact with that model
maybe they need to call a DOT predict
method they want to return some
predictions and and it's like where do
you put that model now well snow park
gives you a way of actually storing that
model in the warehouse itself and then
any kind of external application can can
actually read from that model or call
methods on that model object so it's
nice it's a really cool it makes for a
really cool smooth workflow for many
machine learning uh jobs so here what
I'm showing you here is just a little
code snippet where I'm taking a function
that I have in my local notebook
environment and I'm saying hey take this
function take everything that it does
and just put it
in the warehouse and let me run it there
and so the very last line is actually me
calling uh a training
um training function that I defined in
my notebook but actually letting it run
sort of remotely in the snowflake
Warehouse so this is pretty interesting
and that's the only sort of little bit
that you have to add is this
registration so I'll show you how all of
this works in practice as well
okay let me just quickly
move over to a notebook
and I hope you can see this so I'm going
to
walk you through a bit of what snow park
actually looks like in The Notebook
I won't spend too much time on all of
the Nitty Gritty but basically this is
deep note that you're looking at here
I can give you a quick lay of the land
we have like workspace
uh workspaces here on the on the left
and projects it's slightly different
than how Jupiter Works uh where we have
workspaces and workspaces contain
projects and projects contain notebooks
I also happen to have an integration
with the snowflake Warehouse here in my
notebook and this makes it so I can
write SQL against my warehouse natively
in the notebook so it's python plus SQL
so here I am in the notebook I'm
authenticating into my snow park session
so I won't I won't share too much of
that with you
um in fact I think I'll just skip down
to
where the fun machine learning bits
happen and sort of describe a few things
that happened along the way
okay so I'm going to share this notebook
with you as well
um so that you can see all of the
specific details but just remember that
this notebook shows you how to take raw
data and I actually bundle I bundle the
data the parquet file for this raw data
right in the notebook itself so when you
um when I share the resources later you
can duplicate this into your own
workspace and as long as you have a
snowflake account which is free and a
deep note account which is free you'll
be able to actually run this entire
machine learning pipeline for yourself
and see how it all works
um but yeah this notebook will actually
execute and and put into practice this
this entire pipeline that I've shown
here where we have raw data through a
series of transformation stages all the
way to something we can use for machine
learning and so um I'm gonna skip
through all of the Transformations that
I'm doing but you can see it's just
following exactly the visualization that
I uh that I showed so here's all the
associated code eventually though you
get down here and you're like okay hey
my data is all transformed I want to
start looking at it now I want to start
uh
um
visualizing it and eventually I want to
work towards training it and deploying
it
there's a few things to mention here let
me hide this
UI
um
as I mentioned before
snowpark gives you this data frame
abstraction and so you can call these if
you call these methods this is actually
something that I showed in my Google
Slides earlier and then you get this you
can convert the
the results set to pandas whenever you
call this to pandas method which is a
snow park method then it actually brings
the data into memory in the notebooks
environment
okay
um and so here you can see I'm just uh
looking at this telecommunications data
set I'm I'm actually concerned with uh
the customers who are churning and in
this case I can look at the whether they
churned or not uh how many churned based
on the kind of contract they had so uh
pretty straightforward stuff but I just
wanted to show you how that looks in The
Notebook
you can even call the dot explain method
if you like on um on any data frame and
what it will do is actually show you the
underlying SQL which could be quite
helpful because after all these things
are really just
like wrapping around SQL
um part of what makes deep notes so nice
and and such a good fit for snow park as
you can see
um is that we have a lot of sort of
built-in Eda helpers and superpowers
that help you sort of understand your
data without having to write a lot of
code and um so so it's a good fit you
can actually see here that I have taken
a sample from my warehouse from this
table Telco data set or
telecommunications data set I've brought
it into the notebook's memory with two
pandas and I've just displayed the first
50 rows in deep note and you can see
right away without doing any work you
get like ratios of your data you get
histograms and and different things you
can sort and filter and
um even paginate and download this data
so this is pretty nice uh this is a
really I think if you're working with
data you you sort of want to be able to
understand it as quickly as possible so
we try to build these things in
um we also have these various different
kinds of blocks and so here I have a
chart block or you can think of it like
a special kind of cell
and again we can we can pass data frames
into these chart blocks and explore them
very very quickly without having to
write a lot of code
this is actually great for things like
colored scatter charts or or grouped
histograms like this which are kind of
annoying to make if you have to write
code for them all the time so here you
it's very simple you just pass in a data
frame to the Chart block and then you
point these you point these fields to
columns in your data frame and we use
the underlying Vega light visualization
library to render these charts so this
is quite nice
um
again I mentioned earlier that we're
also connected to our snowflake instance
and so here you can see that I'm I'm
actually writing just SQL this is an SQL
block and again we can start exploring
our data you can even
parameterize queries in different ways
by having these sort of widgets and
blocks and to sort of add like a UI
element uh to your to your queries or
your python or or your python blocks as
well so this is quite nice uh when you
start to think about hey I've got a
great tool for transformation all in
Python thanks to snow park and then I
can with the snow park data frame API
and some of these built-in Eda
superpowers I can really start to
understand my data without having to
duplicate a lot of code or have to think
too much
so
I want to get to the machine learning
part and just give you this sense of of
how this all works
so suppose you're a data scientist and
you're exploring you're sort of done
with this like initial exploration you
want to start
um prototyping a model you end up with
you know in this case I just have a
model that's returning some accuracy
scores and it's it's it's also saving
the model object
uh itself so I can actually use it
um
and it's of course it's training it's
actually fitting the model and it's
doing all kinds of standard SK learn
types of things
and so you have this function and you're
like okay this this is cool this works
in my laptop I'm very happy with this
fine
but it's working again this is working
in the client or locally
and so there's no problem I can call
this and run it locally and I will get
the output back that that I expect fair
enough what's really cool about snow
park though
um is that you're like okay I've got
this function but is there a way I can
just move this to run let's say push
down or run it down in the uh in the
warehouse itself
and yes as I mentioned before this is
one of the the value propositions for
snow park you can simply take the
function that you've defined in your
local environment or your client however
you want to think about that
and you can say hey take that function
give it these libraries you know this is
sort of going to help Define the
environment and
um store store everything in some
storage location uh in the
in the snowflake warehouse and then
that's basically it that's you
registering a local function but you're
registering it sort of remotely once you
do that
that anything that function did
including like saving the model object
itself all of those things get stored on
the snowflake side in in the stages that
you define I just think of the stage as
like a sort of a place to store
artifacts or a place to store assets
that you want to access later and any of
the output that that function
um
produces
um well you can interact with all of
that just by
calling that function that you've
registered
along with any inputs that that function
takes and so I want to contrast this
line
which calls this function train churn
prediction model and passes this data
set in this is actually running this
will actually run in the snowflake
Warehouse itself and of course it
Returns the output that you'd expect and
a slight contrast with this which runs
exactly the same function with exactly
the same data set but runs it in your
local environment so this is part of
what snow park is bringing to the table
hey it's like
prototype your models in your notebook
and then when when you want you can
actually run that right next to the data
uh in the snowflake Warehouse
um of course uh you might be thinking
well you saved that object in a stage
in the snowflake Warehouse how do you
actually do anything with that uh with
that model with that object because
typically when you
when you train a model you want to
actually Pass New values into that
model's predict method and return back
predictions like this is a
classification model after all
so you can do that
um by
um
you can do that by uh
by using these so-called snow snowpark
UD apps or user-defined functions and
basically without getting into too many
of the details the user-defined function
will just allow you to actually call the
predict method on the object that's
living in the warehouse and the way
these functions work is kind of
interesting actually if you look at this
select statement this is basically you
can think of it like SQL if it makes it
a bit easier but it's saying hey for
every row I return from this select
statement can you actually take those
values and pass them into the model's
predict method and this is like kind of
interesting because you it feels like
you're just calling an SQL method but
that SQL method or that SQL code is also
kind of interacting with python you know
on the back end and calling these this
predict method and so for every single
Row in this result set
I'm actually getting a new column
called predicted churn and this is
actually returning the results of that
predict method
so this is a really really interesting
way of of building machine learning
pipelines where you're storing this
object this is a python object it's
sitting in the cluster or sitting in a
snowflake Warehouse which is like an
anaconda environment and you're saying
hey I can actually call methods on that
object and have them show up alongside
any um any Row in in my result set so
there's you know the sky's the limit can
be quite creative with this you can
imagine something like this driving
let's say
like a dashboard or something right if
you have a streamlit app and you want to
serve up like hey these are the
customers most likely to churn uh you
want to serve that up to your
stakeholders that streamlit app can
essentially be running this python code
which is
connected to your snowflake warehouse
and calling calling that predict method
uh via these UDF functions and then you
know visualizing those some in some way
uh in your dashboard so this is really
really cool
um you can of course very easily chain
these methods together as well uh and
and actually write those predictions to
like to a new table let's say uh and
this is also a really nice way of of of
of taking that that data and you know
not making it ephemeral but actually
saving it right next to your data so
this is this is also really um
a really good method a really good
technique okay so I want to just very
quickly uh go back to
my presentation
and give you a bit of a summary of Where
what we've learned
okay
so snow park does a lot of things
it's great for transforming your data in
your Warehouse of course you can do
anything that you can do with SQL you
can pretty much do that with snowpark
but it also adds these like machine
learning
um use cases on top of that allowing you
to take a function that you have running
locally
and basically Define a conda environment
essentially where that function and
everything it needs can actually run
right into the warehouse or run right in
the warehouse next to your data itself
so this is already huge because you
don't have to you know switch to a
different language you don't have to
switch to a different Tool uh your your
prototyping code and your and your the
code that runs in the in the warehouse
are essentially the same and then on top
of that any objects that are stored in
the warehouse can be accessed with these
udfs so that you can sort of Drive
dashboards and a front end on top of
what what's happening in your Warehouse
it really does feel like
us for some people a quite a smooth way
of doing machine learning workflows
which are
like notoriously hard to productionize
and then as you saw of course we are
using deep note as this control surface
really that's what we're doing we're
saying hey we need a control surface for
all of this and there's a whole bunch of
superpowers that are built into that
that help you with exploratory data
analysis like these rich data frames you
can explore without writing code and of
course chart blocks and these UI these
widgets so all of these things together
uh ideally they make a data scientist's
life much easier
um if you want to you can point your
camera at this QR code and um you'll be
taken to uh like notebook resources you
can use to uh to actually poke around
and and experience no Park and deep note
for yourself
so uh that about does it for me thank
you very very much and I have some time
for questions
thanks for that Alan
um let's uh let me go ahead and
um look at the job board here
um yeah we have a few questions for you
um
let's see uh uh would you have the link
of this notebook
I do
um where's the best place for me to
share that if you just type it in the
chat I'll make sure that it gets out
here right yeah yeah I'll make sure all
right yes yes indeed
um I can do that
um also yeah that for those who are who
are going to be here later as well the
QR code will take you to things uh but
I'll share it with you perfect perfect
all right uh next question
um we have is um performance wise how
does snow park compare to other major
Frameworks like Pi spark plain pandas
Etc
yeah that's that's a good question
um
my understanding is that if you had
like a if you wanted to pay for like a
really performant cluster on like AWS
EMR or something and you wanted to Pi
spark at it you could probably work on
like just gigantic data sets and have
everything distributed and if you really
need that then go for it
um I think and you'd have to ask the
snow park
people or the snowflake people how they
how they can actually provision better
machines for you if you need data at
scale at that level but like
um the conda environment that I'm using
right now in the notebook that I just
showed you I don't think it could
compare performance wise uh in terms of
data storage and RAM capabilities as
like if you spun up a cluster like an
EMR cluster or something so I think you
you could check with the snowflake
people to see
uh to see how upgrading that environment
would work but
um there are currently I think at least
for my environment some limitations so
I'm definitely not going to be uh
training on millions of rows of data or
anything in this environment
so basically I think if you want to pay
for it you can you can scale it up but
I'm not sure how that works